كبير على بعدي 10 كيلو مترات من الحدود
الروسيه ينشغل هؤلاء العمال في اصلاح محطه
الكهرباء التي تعرضت للقذف المدفعي هل ترى
هذه الحفره
حدثت بسبب قصف المدفعيه الروسيه ما ادى
الى تعطيل عمل المحطه وبالتالي الى قطع
التيار الكهربائي عن العديد من القرى
السكنيه في هذه المنطقه
توجد هذه المحطه في خط المواجهه بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه تعرضت للقذف
المدفعي المكثف ليله الاشهر الاخيره
يعد اصلاحها مخاطره لهؤلاء الرجال
وللكسندر الذي خلف زميله بعد ان قتل في
حادث انفجار لغمين في المنطقه
في ظل الظروف الحاليه لن نستطيع اصلاح
الاعطال ومدى القرى بالكهرباء قبل الصيف
المقبل العديد من البنى التحتيه تقع على
الحدود مع روسيا لذلك يكون من الصعب علينا
الوصول اليها لان الجنود لن يسمح لنا
بالمرور قبل الحرب الروسيه كانت تعداد هذه
البلده الصغيره يقارب ثلاثه الاف غادروها
كلها ولم يبقى منهم الى 25 يعيشون في ظلام
من دامس
قضينا خمسه اشهر في القبر في قبض بيته
الذي لا تتعدى مساحته ثلاثه امتار عاش
فيكتور وزوجته الجحيم
كنت انام هنا مع كلب بينما كانت زوجتي
تماما هناك
تعرض فيكتور للاصابه بسبب شظيه قذيفه
مدفعيه يعيش منذ اشهر بدون كهرباء لكن
لتحمل هذا البرد القارس لابد ان يقوم بجمع
الحطب لموقده القديمه
لقطع خشبي بعض الاشجار التي دمرتها
الشغايه كلما اعود الى منزلي اشعر بيدي
متجمتين
كل ما يامله
لم يتبقى في هذه القريه الى الانقاض وبعض
السكان الذين يرفضون مغادرتها لانهم لا
يملكون مامون اخر يصارعون للبقاء احياء في
حرب تكادت عامها الاول